i talk about china
china yeah china
and
you know we saw a lot of this during
kovid like what are we dependent on but
we're dependent on china for food
and a lot of people don't recognize that
china limit china
china is coming for us
i tell people i'm like if you look at
mao during the chinese industrial
revolution the great leap forward mao
knew that he needed nuclear technology
there's been five emperors in china
emperors
that's what i'll call them dictators
whatever leaders
great ones whatever dragon lords so like
microaggression and so
but if you look at what they did he
understood that they needed nuclear
technology so what did he do he traded
food to the russians in exchange for
nuclear technology starved his own
people 30 million people died during
peace time and he got the nuclear weapon
they have a 5 000 year plan all right
they understand that by by
enslaving their own people for cheap
labor because americans exist for
consumption
i want it now and i want it cheap
and it's like my house i go in there how
many how much do i need right it's
that's cheap it's only three bucks
another potato peeler
you never know
so so so how many potato peelers did you
actually have in my house okay i did
have five that's a lot i did have i kept
two
shout out to cuisinart but
i uh i was like if you look at them
they're smart because what they did is
they understood the american psychology
they understand that americans are
overconfident because from childhood
they're told you're the best you're good
you get praised for things you never
deserved they they're entitled and lazy
chinese are the opposite right so
they're like marching forward to their 5
000 year destiny
and so what do we do we outsource
everything to them for super cheap goods
and in turn handcuff ourselves to them
right including our medications the
world's most critical medications are
made in china
and so you know china is on the move and
their military is now expeditionary
they're providing aid to foreign
countries they've got their jets and
they got hypersonic missiles and let me
tell you something they're not over here
like trying to pass the pt test okay oh
i didn't you know gotta go to fep
because i didn't make it by the way my
rights matter you don't toe the line in
the chinese army you wind up as biochar
okay they don't no need for you and and
xi xin ping said that
you know if we try to stand against the
chin this is two months ago in a live
speech he said out there show a force
and he said you will meet a great wall
of steel made by 1.8 billion chinese
that are unified
what are we over here like don't go over
here like i don't like you like so
they banned all girly men on tv
there is no
boy bands allowed social media turns off
at 10 o'clock at night
and and what are they preparing for to
be a world leader
and who are they in lock stuff with the
russians
right and and because they see the
united states dwindling because
consumption consumerism entitlement
overconfidence uh and and this desire to
tell people what's right and wrong you
know like we have these things and then
what happened in afghanistan right we're
no longer a force for good
we are we better rethink because this
enemy is not like an afghani running
around in pajamas
these dudes are probably genetically
modified who knows what they're going to
do they might unzip their fake chinese
bodies and come out and just be like
who knows right they are genetically
modifying super soldiers forbes just or
was at a time or whatever just had a
thing on them so we are facing a time
right now where this entitlement and all
these things that we have are coming
home to roost on us
and you know buyer beware
because if the cable breaks if the earth
even burps okay if it just rumbles in
the wrong place and the power goes out
for say two months
millions upon mil there won't be enough
excavators to dig the holes for the
bodies that will burn
people
oh no
but it's the truth think about it if
you're living in a 25 million dollar
high-rise on the 98th floor
and the power goes out
where do you get your next sandwich from
by time you make it down every store
will be gone all the food will be gone
there will be no water your well pumps
won't work just think about it
life is held together by a cable
and we never think that that cable is
going to ever break and you know who's
holding part of that cable
network is china
and i don't think that china would have
picked a fight with us but i think we've
put to fight with them and because here
we are just bloating bloating bloating
bloating bloating
and
and and they're refining refining
refining refining refining
so i mean if if putin invades ukraine
i bet you i bet you see china and china
go after taiwan simultaneously
i wouldn't be surprised
and then they could launch hypersonic
missiles and vaporize our fleet in two
seconds and then it's either go nuclear
or stand down